[Music]
how that keeps happening um so you want
to see what a typical uh a typical
argument looks like in portland
we're going to play a game that's called
who's worse um and i think adonis paul
calls this a hate hate hate video oh no
it's a hate hate hate that means you're
gonna just everyone in this video sucks
the guy the only person that's awesome i
like these kind of videos everyone sucks
the only person who's awesome in this
video is a guy filming okay watch
this is portland as you'll see in a
second
i don't have time to waste some
colonizing she told me she told me to go
back to where i came from you're driving
home because we
we're [ __ ] kind and we make space
okay and as someone who's from here as
well i'm so tired of people driving like
you just did all right get on my face
let's get out my admit you're [ __ ]
wrong and then it's not all those things
admit
you have a colonizer mindset right now
guys do it marsh you're both awful oh
they're terrible kids kids kids you're
both terrible this is one of those i
just want to get out of my car with my
gun in my hand be like everyone back
there everyone get a car we're done
brandishing it just pointing it at the
ground just get out and go we're done
everyone back to their cars
i hate both of you about race yeah
[Music]
these people live in their own
self-imposed hell and i think it's
hilarious but you're talking about like
people driving like [ __ ] and stuff
so now you're both out of your cars
blocking traffic having an argument yes
so now you're both [ __ ]
if you want things to change when you
[ __ ] oh so it's on me
hold the race card don't [ __ ] type do
not call the shut up and don't even get
in her face do not get in her face
you're a [ __ ] colonizer bro i love
this taking out
an impression on me right now
meanwhile in florida that that chick
twerking again meanwhile in florida
we are you guys are the middle okay now
normal person's finally going like i
don't know get out of the street i don't
know who that woman is
but she's the only one in this video i
like so far can you guys [ __ ]
straight yeah that's that's great it's
probably the hot takes lady guy last
sane woman in portland exactly
it's important blocking traffic it's
important give it a moment it's
important yeah our our two deferring
opinions that neither one of us is going
to change the others on is important is
more important than everyone getting to
work on time none of you are important
the amount of [ __ ] entitlement people
walk around with no i stop everyone's
day right now because this is important
i need my i need my binky it's like you
know it's like a baby getting a whole
plane to turn around and go back to the
tarmac because they left their binky
inside
i actually just looked it up guys uh
it's right it's right there in
portland's uh civil code you can't block
the right-of-way traffic
unless it's important unless it's
important i read i read that too yeah
unless you're having a discussion about
colonizers then it's fine yeah
if you want anything to change if you
want shut up it's not on me to change
it's on you and your colonizer mindset
so get the [ __ ] out of my face
lady i i just want to have her scream in
his face i just had my rice taken from
me yeah
i wanted to scream listen hear your
prayer
[Laughter]
this like weird mindset now where you
can just scream at white people grind
set this grind set where you can just
scream at any white person now and and
basically
just yell about their rights but i know
they're both terrible but again i'm
asking the question she's probably she's
worse okay here's what we're gonna do
cuz there's a little more to this video
but we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
put a pole up okay all right let's see
let's see who is
worse
uh we need an okay so uh
worker
or
book
shop
owner okay so who's worse and here's
your options casino worker or bookshop
owner all right you guys decide amongst
yourselves
you white lady
i hate him more just because he's crying
about the racial [ __ ] i think i hate her
more because she's blocking traffic but
they're both blocked oh that's a good
point they're both blocking traffic okay
good call go call they're both terrible
get out of my face because i'm done with
this conversation then you'd be walking
your way [ __ ] colonized oh there's
work you don't care it's not on me
wow we're right down the middle we're 50
50 right now he's nuts too though man
well guys i would say hold off your
votes to the end there's there's
something fun at the end
i'm not taking any [ __ ] i'm not
taking any directions from a white lady
everyone needs to hear how angry you are
but it's not about this
it's not they're not angry about this
it's not about what just happened white
women talking down to people is one of
my favorite though i mean i think she's
worse i'm gonna go with her still man i
would love to just get out of my car
with a bat walk over and start hitting
both of their cars and they're winning
yes
now move
i'm driving away
why can't you just walk you're in my
space
you're in my speed you got in my skates
bro get back in your car somebody else
bro get back in your car
ah you're breathing my air you [ __ ]
colonize it
get out of my face
and don't give me those white tears and
a fake white girl
understanding
you don't know the pain of my people
he's the worst now right he's the worst
now he's the worst he's not going back
and forth you live in portland your
piece of [ __ ] i just went with my people
and my people and my people i'm so sick
of these genetic alcoholics
[ __ ] talking down to people my pee
poo he just went with my pee poo christ
almighty that he's the worst now right
he should be manning a blackjack table
my pee poo
get out
get out i'm gonna stand here with you
until you walk away bro this is nuts
it's still close it's like 51.49 it did
this pole
and then you made it about race and
that's [ __ ] up you told me she told me
to get back to where i came from i think
she meant like your house i mean i'm not
defending her but i think what she meant
was leave
he has out-of-state license plates does
he oh you'll see yes so that's what she
was saying you'll see at the end of the
video there's something at the end of
the video you're gonna love it so so he
is worse yeah she and her white
colonizer mindset pump me in
oh i don't care
okay so the video ends there but guess
what
hold on where is it i have the part two
i have the part two
i promise you i it's here somewhere
sure replies
come on there okay part two here it is i
didn't come back to where it came from
just because i made a simple mistake i
don't think he meant like you pulled in
front of my car in my lane yeah a simple
mistake okay so hold on so he also is
the aggressor he cut her off and
all right so he's the worst then he's
there yeah just to get around the car
disability
but i hope you have a conversation about
this
don't worry plenty of us are going to
have a conversation about this okay shut
the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up help you
and i hope you go back to [ __ ] europe
i'm actually from vermont
my parents own a blueberry farm but
that's not important right now okay we
have to have a conversation
it's not on me it's not hey hey tweets
on iphone who invented the internal
combustion engine
hey um sir i don't think a door is
closing
and start being humans doing so she
they're both terrible he's definitely
worse though
he cuts her off he has out of state
plates so she probably because like the
same way i always feel the royce feels
when you drive around you get caught up
but you're like go back to [ __ ] new
yorker or go back to michigan you're
probably rationally angry i don't care
what state they're from if they ain't
florida plates beat it
now you're going to cut me off
in my own [ __ ] town i don't think so
where's the plate
from give me a second i can't make it
out
give me this i bet it's got it they're
in oregon it's got to be like washington
right idaho or something you know what i
bet it's idaho
all right
she's one of those huh buy locally
she's someone that's she's someone that
fred armisen would be playing in
portlandia
that's who she is i bet she
[ __ ] though
oh smash for sure i'm going smash for
sure she [ __ ] yeah
i bet she's let a lot of people call an
eyes or [ __ ]
uh let's see here uh read read read i'd
rather be here now visualize world peace
xyz peace
trans flag
oh god lady everything
and that's the whole [ __ ] thing
imagine living there on ironically i i
i'll say this let's can we can we see
the end of okay we're gonna see the end
of the poll ready
55 casino worker was worse and i'm going
to agree with the chat i'm agreeing with
the chat he was
clearly
it started she was worse yeah but you
could clearly see once more information
came in it was like yeah you were like
okay well clearly we know what the
problem is also no man should be that
emotional about like
the
racial stuff you know what i mean like
you should be a [ __ ]